[Musik]
ja
lösung
[Musik]
der fall kachelmann der wettermoderator
wird beschuldigt seine ex geliebte
brutal vergewaltigt zu haben
er bestreitet die tat
seit monaten sucht das landgericht
mannheim nach der wahrheit und muss
feststellen dass keine verlässlichen
tatspuren existieren
noch werde ich nur ein stück zurück
der einundzwanzigste prozesstag drei
monate nach verfahrensbeginn
kachelmanns verteidiger geht jetzt ohne
großes medien aufsehen in den
gerichtssaal das interesse ist abgeflaut
nur noch wenige journalisten sind da zum
beispiel die gerichtsreporterin des
magazins der spiegel
gisela friedrichsen
an diesem dezembertag geschieht
außerordentliches
also für mich war der tag an dem der
spuren sachverständige kam zwar zwei
tage vor weihnachten eigentlich der in
der der aufregendste und der muss sagen
für mein bild entscheidende es ist der
auftritt von diesem mann gerhard bäßler
der kriminaltechniker er untersuchte
unter anderem das mutmaßliche
tatwerkzeug das messer
das gericht will heute herausfinden was
für spuren bessler am tatort fand
kameras sind nur vor der verhandlung
erlaubt während des prozesses sind
jedoch zeichner zugelassen
zuerst referiert kriminaltechniker
besser ausführlich über die
untersuchungstechnik erst am schluss
wartet er mit der überraschung auf er
habe sagt bessler am angeblichen
tatwerkzeug ein messer keine eindeutig
nachweisbaren dna-spuren von jörg
kachelmann gefunden kachelmanns
verteidiger johann schwenn fragt die
ex-geliebte sagte gegenüber der polizei
jörg kachelmann aber ihr das messer 15
minuten lang an den hals gehalten wenn
das stimmt müssen sie da nicht seine
spuren finden ja ich möchte spuren
finden antwortet bäßler
doch es hat keine
an dem tatmesser dem angeblichen
tatmesser sie hat eine ganz zentrale
rolle
wenn es ist schwere vergewaltigung
angeklagt schwere vergewaltigung
deswegen weil eben ein gefährliches
werkzeug eingesetzt wurde wenn daran
nicht die spuren sind die eigentlich
sein müssten wenn sie sich wenn sich die
tat so abgespielt hätte wie sie
angeklagt ist oder wie die frau das aus
sagt dann ist doch die sache erledigt
eigentlich die staatsanwaltschaft wusste
monate zuvor das beste am messer keine
dna spuren von kachelmann fangt dennoch
so geräte sie in ihrer pressemitteilung
das gegenteil
die gerichtsreporterin sabine rückert
verfolgt den prozess für die
wochenzeitung die zeit
die staatsanwaltschaft hat die
öffentlichkeit von anfang an in die irre
geführt mit mit ihren mit ihren
öffentlichen äußerungen
sie hat das gegenteil dessen behauptet
was was realität war
[Musik]
achter februar 2010 11 uhr abends
schwetzingen eine deutsche kleinstadt
eine fahrstunde von frankfurt entfernt
die meisten bewohner schlafen bereits
als jörg kachelmann eintrifft ihn
erwartet die radiomoderatorin de die
hier in einer kleinen dachwohnung lebt
die frage was genau in dieser nacht
passierte beschäftigt das landgericht
mannheim seit monaten
der anwalt der radiomoderatorin wird
wenige wochen nach dieser nacht das
verhältnis zu kachelmann so definieren
die beziehung hat vor über elf jahren
begonnen es war ein interview dass meine
mandantin seinerzeit mit herrn
kachelmann geführt hat ich glaube es
ging auch über das wetter und im rahmen
dieses interviews haben was ich
kennengelernt sich sympathisch gefunden
und es kam dann zu dieser beziehung oder
lebenspartnerschaft die bis zum
tatzeitpunkt angedauert hat es war aber
weder das interesse meiner mandantin und
mutmaßt man auch nicht das interesse von
herrn kachelmann diese beziehung die
öffentlichkeit zu tragen aber gleichwohl
es war keine geheime beziehung
für kachelmann ist die radio moderatorin
nicht die einzige frau während der
angeblichen lebenspartnerschaft mit dir
heiratete er eine andere frau lässt sich
wieder scheiden und gleichzeitig pflegt
er noch eine vielzahl weitere
beziehungen parallel bei einigen ist
auch gewalt mit dem spiel eine geliebte
zum beispiel erzählt dem gericht er habe
sie massiv bedrängt auch andere
berichten er hätte grenzen verletzt die
radiomoderatorin d trifft eher
unregelmäßig im jahr 2009 beispielsweise
haben sie sich lediglich zehnmal
getroffen
für die bunte verfolgt die
stellvertretende chefredakteurin tanja
may den prozess sie hat sich intensiv
mit kachelmanns verhältnis zu ex
geliebten auseinandergesetzt auch wenn
man sich nicht täglich gesehen hat war
doch der kontakt täglich da das beweisen
ja auch diese fünf glaube ich dicken
gefüllten leitz ordner die die
staatsanwaltschaft bzw das gericht
vorliegen hat mit chat-protokollen und
e-mail-verkehr zwischen mutmaßlichem
opfer und angeklagten und ja angeblich
sie hat ihn geliebt sie hat geglaubte
sei die einzige frau in seinem leben
also wenn man sich mal vorstellen als
die polizei ihre wohnung dann durchsucht
hat er hatte bei ihr kein einziges
kleidungsstück
er hatte keine zahnbürste kein
rasierapparat nichts sie wusste nicht
mal die adresse von ihm wo er wohnt sie
wusste nichts von ihm das einzige die
einzige spur von ihm war ein foto des am
kühlschrank lebte alles also elf jahre
lang und so ein mann der der ab und zu
mal vorbeikommt durchs bett wandert und
gleich wieder weg ist
das soll dann der mann fürs leben sein
oder der lebenspartner also ich meine
das muss man auch erstmal glauben die
glaubt an die liebe ihres lebens wie sie
wortwörtlich formuliert man suggeriert
ihr in seinen botschaften
sie sei für ihn die einzige im november
2000 06 melden ihr beispielsweise weil
ich dir vertraut weil du mir sicherheit
gibst weil ich für dich versuchen möchte
die ein kind zu machen auch andere
frauen erhalten von kachelmann ähnliche
botschaften die emma herausgeberin alice
schwarzer verfolgt den prozess für die
boulevardzeitung bild ihr urteil über
kachelmann steht fest dass keine
moralische frage aber doch eine frage
auch der menschenwürde also wie man
frauen behandelt menschen behandelt ob
man eine frau jahrelang in dem glauben
lässt du bist die einzige ich werde dich
heiraten von dem möchte ich kinder und
dann gibt es da eine 2 3 4 ich weiß
nicht wie viele
da muss es schon eine gewissen mangel
oder eine abwesenheit an
empathiefähigkeit geben also ein mensch
mit mitgefühl tut das ja anderen ohne
not nicht an nicht wir sind alle
menschen und die meisten von uns kennen
konfliktsituationen in beziehung ja dass
da vielleicht mal jemand anders ist man
fängt an zu schwindeln man dachte ich du
lieber gott was machst du nur ja so da
kann man reinkommen aber das hatte ja
system und da geht es ja weniger um
gefühle es geht ja auf sich um macht
klar ist der erfolgreiche wetter
moderator führt eine art doppelleben mit
mehreren geliebten gleichzeitig
sie waren sich eigentlich alle einig
darin dass es ein sehr ein hoch
intelligenter mann ist jörg kachelmann
dass er wahnsinnig charmant sein kann
und alle haben gesagt er hat uns das
gefühl gegeben oder hat mir das gefühl
gegeben ich bin die schönste die
besonders ich bin die einzige frau in
seinem leben und im nachhinein sagen die
frauen vielleicht hat man mal was geahnt
aber eigentlich wollte man es nie
wahrhaben weil es bestand ja jeden tag
kontakt also die frauen haben gesagt er
hat jeden tag mehrfach angerufen man hat
gechattet man hat e mail ausgetauscht
teilweise hat man sich auch gesehen und
er doch immer wohl versucht bei allen
wichtigen gelegenheiten dabei zu sein
also sprich geburtstag oder silvester
solche oder weihnachten das sind ja
alles dinge die man mit seinem partner
macht und deswegen bestand für die
frauen eigentlich keinen grund daran zu
zweifeln dass diese liebe echt sein soll
was erwarten die frauen
von der liebe was wird da hinein
geheimnis in eine beziehung die nur per
sms stattfindet oder in irgendwelchen
in irgendwelche e mails das ist mir ganz
unten ganz unbegreiflich wie man wie man
da jahrelang sich davon brotkrumen
ernährt und auch tatsächlich auf eine
hochzeit wartet dass man da will man
betrogen sein anders kann ich mir das
nicht vorstellen jeder normale mensch
oder jede normale frau hätte irgendwann
die nase voll gehabt und zwar relativ
rasch das waren ja eigentlich alles ganz
eigenständige frauen oft journalistin
mit berufen selbstbewusster attraktive
frauen es hat da offensichtlich ein
system gegeben diese frauen glauben zu
lassen dass er sie braucht nicht wäre ja
auch einiges gehört dass er mit humor
und auch mit mitleid gearbeitet hat
nicht und wissen sie auch dank der neuen
medien diese permanente präsent und so
kleine tricks und ich will kinder von
dir und so irgendwie haben diese frauen
sich alle einen rollen lassen und also
ein buch darüber wie lol ich frauen ein
ich glaube da das könnte ein bestseller
aus der feder von karmann werden er lädt
zweiter januar 2010 also rund einen
monat vor der umstrittenen acht die
radiomoderatorin die in das angeblich
gemeinsam geplante haus im schwarzwald
ein zurück in schwetzingen plant sie die
inneneinrichtung sie meldet ihm haben
wir wenn man alles fertig ist dort auch
platz für ein klavier ich denke wir
müssen oben einen raum mit badewannen
und waschbecken auf der rechten seite
und wohnen schlafen klavierspielen links
im januar 2010 treffen sie sich dreimal
jedes mal hätten sie wunderbaren sex
gehabt gibt die später zu protokoll
meist war auch eine spur gewalt mit dem
spiel peitschen handschellen aber nie
messer
das nächste treffen ist auf den 8
februar 2010 vereinbart die
verhängnisvolle nacht
radiomoderatoren de erhält von
kachelmann die chat botschaft du musst
nichts zum essen machen zur
zeitersparnis für unsere hauptaufgabe
mit hauptaufgabe ist sex gemeint doch in
dieser nacht endet die angebliche
lebenspartnerschaft abrupt
die gibt später zu protokoll sie habe
jörg kachelmann zur rede stellen wollen
weil sie den verdacht hegt dass sie sei
nicht die einzige in seinem leben
da sei ja zum tier geworden und habe sie
mit einsatz eines messers vergewaltigt
der sprecher der staatsanwaltschaft
mannheim erklärt später
jeweil hat er nach dem ergebnis unserer
ermittlungen der geschädigten ein messer
an den hals gehalten daher der vorwurf
der qualifizierten tatbegehung besonders
schwere vergewaltigung in tateinheit mit
gefährlicher körperverletzung dadurch
den messer einsatz auch verletzungen
entstanden sein sollen
die radio moderatorin ist jetzt
anzeigeerstatterin
kachelmann droht deshalb eine
gefängnisstrafe mindestens fünf jahre
haft sieht das gesetz vor
wir haben verletzungen im halsbereich
vorgefunden die nach dem ergebnis der
rechtsmedizinischen untersuchung durch
den messer einsatz hervorgerufen worden
sein können und nach unserer auffassung
auch worden sind also nicht selbst
beigefügt vom opfer das schließen wir
aus
landgericht mannheim
auftritt des rechtsmediziners seiner
mutter erst der mann der die
radiomoderatorin am tag nach der
angeblichen vergewaltigung untersucht
hatte auf ihn stützt sich die
staatsanwaltschaft mit ihrer aussage
selbstverletzung könne man ausschließen
erneut gibt es eine überraschung
ich kann hier nicht beweisen dass der
angeklagte kachelmann diese verletzungen
erzeugt hat sagte rechtsmediziner matan
und ich halte es für möglich dass froh
die sich diese verletzungen selbst
beigebracht hat
wieder anders als die staatsanwaltschaft
behauptet hat obwohl rechtsmediziner
metern bereits in seinem ersten
gutachten schrieb eine selbstbeibringung
wäre möglich die staatsanwaltschaft hat
es ignoriert
der sachverständige selber kann weder
nachweisen dass die verletzungen fremd
beigebracht sind noch nachweisen dass
sie selbst beigebracht sind also
sein gutachten ist nach seiner ansicht
kein baustein im gebäude der anklage
dabei schien kachelmann zuvor praktisch
und verurteilt wenigstens hatte man
diesen eindruck wenn man deutsche medien
verfolgte
doch der reihe nach
zwanzigster märz 2010 jörg kachelmann
landet auf dem flughafen frankfurt
zurück aus vancouver wo er für die ard
an den olympischen winterspielen das
wetter moderiert hatte
eine weitere geliebte wartet auf ihn sie
gehen gemeinsam zu seinem auto parkiert
auf platz nummer 29 hier wartet die
polizei um 11 uhr 45 wird er verhaftet
und ins gefängnis mannheim transportiert
noch weiß die öffentlichkeit nichts von
der verhaftung
zwei tage später informiert die
staatsanwaltschaft ohne namensnennung
trotzdem meldet wenig später das
boulevardblatt bild kachelmann sei
verhaftet worden
es ist das erste von vielen weiteren
lecks bei den justizbehörden
wieder zwei tage später der
haftprüfungstermin steht an überall
journalisten selbst auf den
fensterbänken haben sich fotografen
postiert es ist der auftakt zu einem
medienspektakel der voyeurismus der
kommt natürlich auch nicht zu kurz hier
plötzlich erfährt man hier über einen
einen prominenten was der für ein leben
für ein privatleben geführt hat nichts
hat man ja nie gedacht da ist ein netter
mensch auf dem bildschirm nicht er
erzählt was über die wolken und und hat
der lustige ausdrücke dafür und
plötzlich merkt man hoppla der ist
eigentlich gar nicht so nett sondern war
ein ziemlicher ja ziemlich unsäglicher
typ eigentlich nichts man hat ihnen ja
all die jahre wahrgenommen als lieben
etwas schusseligen
wetteransager oder wettermoderator der
gern auch über blumenkohlwolken spricht
oder sich eine katze auf die schulter
hängt und einfach das recht amüsant
immer gemacht hat und plötzlich soll
dieser mann eine frau vergewaltigt haben
und dieses wie gesagt das auftreten von
dem kachelmann seine nette charmante art
und eben diese schwere des tatvorwurfs
die widersprechen sich ja total und ich
glaube deshalb ist diese ist die
öffentlichkeit und auch natürlich die
medien denn so interessiert an diesem
fall
zuerst wird der polizeiwagen so
hingefahren dass kachelmanns abtransport
nicht zu sehen werden
dann wird der verlaufende kamera und
markiert damit gute bilder gemacht
werden können
jedermann kann in diese situation
geraten indycar ihm angeraten ist und
vor allem wenn dann beim fernsehen ist
da braucht es ja eigentlich nur eine
praktikantin die ihnen anzeigt und der
es erledigt
jeder hat sich mal getrennt von jemand
jeder hat meist weit gehabt oder ist
enttäuscht worden von von seinem partner
und hier sieht man wozu das führen kann
wie ein mann eventuell in eine falle
tappt und
dann macht sich natürlich an diesem
prozess auch der graben klar der
zwischen den geschlechtern verläuft also
viele leute nutzen ja dem prozess auch
für ideologische botschaften und da sind
wir wieder bei frau schwarzer die
natürlich ihre ideologie auf in diesem
prozess hinein projiziert obwohl er
wahrscheinlich damit gar nichts zu tun
hat
zurück nach schwetzingen zurück zum 8
februar 2010 dem tag an dem kachelmann
die radiomoderatorin de besucht am
nächsten tag wird sie der polizei
schwetzingen den verlauf so erzählen sie
sei am nachmittag vom einkaufen
zurückgekommen und habe flugtickets
gefunden ausgestellt auf eine frau und
auf kachelmann das ganze sei im
briefkasten gelegen dazu ein zettel mit
dem inhalt er schläft mit ihr diese
aussage ist eine schlüsselstelle in der
ganzen geschichte
der überraschend gefundene brief mit den
tickets habe alles verändert gibt sie zu
protokoll gab es in kachelmanns leben
noch eine andere frau sie habe
beschlossen ihn an diesem abend zur rede
zu stellen
kachelmann ist inzwischen den
schwetzingen eingetroffen er sagt später
sie hätten sofort sex gehabt sie
hingegen bestreitet
unbestritten ist moderatorin de zeigt
ihm die flugtickets und will ihn zur
rede stellen auszüge aus den aussagen
von de
wer ist die frau auf den flugtickets die
könig nicht die sind gefälscht dann zeig
mir deine chat protokolle von dieser
zeit mache ich nicht
moderatorin de gibt später zu protokoll
da hatte angefangen zu reden hat alles
erzählt dass es stimmt dass er sie kennt
und dass sie nicht die einzige ist und
dass er krank und verrückt ist ich habe
dann gefragt wie viele frauen er hat
nichts gesagt waren es mehr als fünf
nichts gesagt mehr als 10 da hat er auch
nichts gesagt da war mir klar dass es so
viele sind ich hatte so einen ekel und
habe ihn gebeten zu gehen er soll sofort
gehen habe ich gesagt du nie wieder
kommen aber er ging nicht er habe sie
gepackt und aufs bett gestoßen mit einem
messer verletzt und vergewaltigt
falls die anschuldigung stimmt seine ex
freundin
würde das ja heißen für diese nacht dass
er sozusagen
das ihm die freundin aus dem ruder
gelaufen ist dass eine frau die bis
dahin
alles mitgemacht hat sehr viel
mitgemacht hat die sich auch seinen
seinen sexuellen vorlieben gebeugt hat
dass die plötzlich sagt hier halt und
raus ja und wie reagiert dann so ein
mann
kachelmann sagte den ermittlern er habe
sich sofort verabschiedet sie hätten
beide geweint am nächsten tag sei er
nach vancouver abgereist im april 2010
publiziert tanja may in der bunten das
erste interview mit einer ex freundin es
ist die frau deren namen auf den flug
ticket stand sie erhielt für das
interview 50.000 euro in der bunten
beklagte sich bitterlich über kachelmann
doch eine wichtige information fehlt in
der zeitschrift nämlich dass die
ex-geliebte seit langem von ihrer
nebenbuhlerin in schwetzingen wusste sie
selbst habe ihn darüber informiert sagt
kachelmanns verteidiger birkenstock
er handelt sofort und beantragt den
laptop der anzeige erstatte und d zu
untersuchen
erst durch meine intervention ist die
polizei dann dazu bekommen die
die auswertung vorzunehmen am laptop der
anzeigeerstatterin und das hat jetzt zu
den erstaunlichsten ergebnissen geführt
die in der hauptverhandlung dann noch
vorgetragen werden nämlich dazu dass die
anzeigeerstatterin in ganz wesentlichen
punkten bei der anzeige falsche angaben
gemacht in
der tat verändert sich danach vieles
staatsanwaltschaft mannheim zwanzigster
april 2010 zweieinhalb monate nach der
anzeige der wird erstmals mit der laptop
untersuchung konfrontiert frau d könnte
es sein dass sie nicht in allen punkten
die wahrheit gesagt haben frau d
bestreitet doch die staatsanwaltschaft
weiß bereits dass sie lügt aufgrund der
laptop analyse sie fragen nochmals was
am nachmittag des 8 februars passiert
sei original zitate aus der vernehmung
dann kam dieser brief war am 8 februar
frau die ihnen muss klar sein dass dann
wenn es wieder licht stimmt sie in
teufels küche kommen aber es stimmt auch
die staatsanwälte investieren wie war
das mit dem brief der war im briefkasten
wie war ihr im briefkasten
ich verstehe die frage nicht gab es
einen umschlag war der brief
verschlossen ja zugeklebt wann haben sie
den brief gefunden am montag da wird
immer wieder aufgefordert die wahrheit
zu erzählen
sie zieht sich schließlich mit ihrem
anwalt zur beratung zurück danach
erzählt sie eine ganz andere version
sie habe bereits über ein jahr vorher
die flugtickets erhalten und von ihrer
nebenbuhlerin gewusst den brief er
schläft mit ihr habe sie selber
geschrieben
es sind fundamentale punkte sie hat
einen angeblichen anonymen brief der den
streit mit kachelmann
ausgelöst haben soll der ja dann in
diese vergewaltigung geführt haben soll
den hat sie sich selbst geschrieben also
den anonymen brief gab es nicht es ist
zutreffend dass
meine mandantin zwei nicht in der
hauptsache nicht den tatvorwurf
betreffende
angaben von sich aus korrigiert hat das
war bereits im april das geschehen das
gegenüber der staatsanwaltschaft war
also für uns überhaupt nichts neues dass
jetzt die in der presse das so
dargestellt wurde gut das ist die sache
der presse sagt aber für die
anklageerhebung für die glaubhaftigkeit
meiner mandantin bei der
staatsanwaltschaft offensichtlich
keinerlei rolle gespielt
wurde es aus der nase gezogen es gab
gegenbeweise und mit denen wurde sie
konfrontiert und dann hat sie das
brötchen weise eingeräumt und auch nicht
gleich und alles auf einmal sondern ganz
langsam nacheinander und nur das womit
sie konfrontiert war
also niemand hatte einen anonymen brief
geschrieben sie selbst hat sich post
geschickt und hat damit dann
erst herr kachelmann getäuscht und der
das ja geglaubt hat und
und später geben dann die polizei und
die staatsanwaltschaft
trotzdem spielt die aussage korrektur
für die staatsanwaltschaft kaum eine
rolle sie erachtet die moderatorin nach
wie vor als glaubwürdig
das opfer ist mehrfach vernommen worden
und hat im kernbereich
wo es um die tatvorwürfe geht in sich
stimmig und plausibel seiner aussage
aufrechterhalten wir haben keinen anlass
an der glaubwürdigkeit des opfers zu
2000 sie hatte offensichtlich das gefühl
gegen cara nicht anzukommen argumentativ
ja und hatte sich das alles so aufgebaut
hier hat mir aber jemand einen brief
geschickt und guck mal und so weiter
also sie sie hat er mit mit beweisen
konfrontiert ja weil sie offensichtlich
alleine gar nicht stark genug war
dagegen anzukommen das ist unangenehm
und ich finde es auch sehr unangenehm
dass sie das bei der polizei bei der
staatsanwaltschaft erst mal aufrecht
erhalten hat aber sehen sie mal
dieser einen dunklen punkt den die
sympathisanten von kachelmann die
anscheinend von anfang an wussten dass
er unschuldig ist was ich
unverantwortlich finde unverantwortlich
auch der frau gegenüber die sind beide
seiten von kann man höre nicht auf
darüber zu reden aber sie könnten auch
mal erwähnen
dass der angeklagte offensichtlich in
einem
pathologisch anmutenden gespinst von
betrug und flügel mit menschen lebt
fakt ist die flugtickets auslöser des
streits besaß die schon monate vor der
umstrittenen 8 und sie wusste ein jahr
vorher dass kachelmann noch mindestens
eine andere beziehung hatte es gibt ja
eine aussage von dieser frau in den
akten wo sie sagt er hat mich kaputt
gemacht und jetzt mache ich ihn kaputt
also sie ihre rachemotiv oder
und dann darf man eines nicht vergessen
es sind beides menschen erst von den
massenmedien kommen ja auch sie ist ja
eine eine medienfrau sie ist bei einem
bei dem radiosender beschäftigt auch sie
hat gelernt sich auszudrücken und sich
darzustellen oder in ihrer stimme oder
in ihrer art und weise wie sie etwas
vorträgt
über die reine aussage hinaus noch etwas
zu transportieren das können beide von
dieser aussage korrektur bei der
staatsanwaltschaft bekommt die
öffentlichkeit zunächst nichts mit im
gegenteil in diesem kritischen moment
erhalten deutsche medien die meldung
zugespielt am messer seien die dna
spuren von jörg kachelmann gefunden
worden
als die frau nebenklägerin in einer
stadt sympathischen vernehmung zugeben
musste
in einigen bereichen nicht die wahrheit
gesagt zu haben sondern bewusst die
unwahrheit gesagt zu haben hat die
staatsanwaltschaft sie hat bestritten
dass getan zu haben was es aus
ermittlerkreisen seien bekannt geworden
am angeblichen tatmesser seien dna
spuren zu finden dna spuren bei seele
aus jedem krimi ist die überführung aber
es war eine falschmeldung der zweite
verteidiger von kachelmann versuchte
damals herauszufinden wer die
falschmeldung streute ich habe
irgendwann den ermittelnden staatsanwalt
angerufen weil ich in der zeitung
gelesen habe etwas von angeblichen dna
spuren an einem messer das wir uns
komplett unbekannt ich habe ihn
angerufen gefragt was ist das für eine
information er sagte mir das hat er
selber noch nicht schriftlich in der
akte aber seine kriminaltechniker seine
ermittler hätten ihm das schon
telefonisch mitgeteilt die verteidigung
hat erlebt dass in dieser sache die
staatsanwaltschaft die medien gegen
herrn kachelmann eingesetzt hat das
hatte den effekt dass es zu einer
vorverurteilung von unserer mandanten
kam das heißt die öffentlichkeit ging
davon aus er ist schuldig auch diese tat
begangen
ein leck mit einer nachweislich falschen
meldung und das ausgerechnet zum
zeitpunkt als die staatsanwaltschaft
realisiert die aussage der
radiomoderatorin steht auf wackligen
beinen wer hat ein interesse daran die
staatsanwaltschaft weist jede schuld von
sich
wir haben uns da von anfang an
beschränkt auf einer relativ
zurückhaltende medienpolitik und das
wörtlich gehalten von bienen kommen denn
diese das weiß nicht
das weiß ich nicht
nein
landgericht mannheim
ein weiterer prozesstag
im foyer sitzt professor brinkmann
er hat im auftrag der verteidigung die
verletzungen von radio moderatorin de
untersucht
brinkmann ist einer der angesehensten
rechtsmediziner in deutschland
und seitlichem ruf und großer riesige
erfahrung er ist der einzige der
international tätig wird und auch
international veröffentlicht und er ist
er herausgeber mehrerer internationaler
rechtsmedizinischer schrift rein
professor brinkmann sagt vor gericht er
habe versucht sich selber ähnliche
verletzungen beizufügen
zuerst erläutert er die halsverletzung
die idee hatte angeblich eine
schnittwunde verursacht durch
kachelmanns messer einsatz
bringt man sagt eine schnittverletzung
sehe anders aus hier handele es sich
vielmehr um eine schusswunde die nicht
mit einer messerklinge entstanden sein
können dann analysiert er die atome an
den oberschenkeln die haben sich die
radiomoderatoren wohl mit den fäusten
selber beigefügt lautet sein fazit und
zum beleg für selbstbeibringung verweist
er unter anderem auf eine aufnahme die
sich auf ihrem computer fand
auf dem computer der frau
gefunden hat ein ein jahr altes foto da
hatte sie auch sohn blauen fleck am
oberschenkel also nur an einem aber
immerhin auch gleiche lage gleiche größe
in etwa
und circa max sagt sie weiß nicht wie
das entstanden ist und einmal hat sie
gesagt das war ihr kleiner neffe der hat
beim toben seit es entstanden also
unwahrscheinlich eigentlich aber auf die
frage warum sie das fotografiert hat ja
weil sie am verlauf von blauen flecken
interessiert sei also ich weiss ich
kenne niemanden der bei sich selbst
blaue flecken fotografiert aber gut
jedenfalls bringt man hat die große
zweifel geäußert dass das tatsächlich
spuren sind von einer vergewaltigung
sondern hatte eine selbstbeibringung für
wahrscheinlicher gehalten
gefängnis mann 29 juli 2010 seit rund
vier monaten sitzt kachelmann jetzt in
untersuchungshaft
sein verteidiger hat mehrmals dagegen
appelliert unter anderem gestützt auf
das gefundene foto und das fazit
brinkmanns schließlich entscheidet das
oberlandesgericht karlsruhe die vorwürfe
gegen kachelmann sei nicht genügend um
ihn weiterhin zu inhaftieren er wird
gleich aus der untersuchungshaft
freikommen deshalb sind all die reporter
dar
[Musik]
sehr gut
alles sehen sein
[Musik]
wenn man die für sie sich ein kurzer
satz und dann schauen wir mal wer heute
keine erklärung abgeben
ich würde sagen verteidiger wäre
natürlich genug vor empfinden dieses
klarstellen muss schlosses
landesgerichts vom heutigen tage in dem
beschluss ist die unschuldsvermutung
wieder auferstanden diese verfahren und
die rechtsstaatlichkeit ist zurück
das recherchiert wurde in kachelmanns
privatleben und das da ist seine gesamte
persönlichkeit runter geschrieben wurde
und da irgendwelche feinde befragt
wurden die ihn irgendwie scheiße fanden
und dann machen die zeitungen geld damit
mit der beschädigung des herrn
kachelmann wird verdient ich finde das
sensationell wurden los und eine
wirkliche eine üble entwicklung in der
medienlandschaft
[Musik]
es ist ein
seltsamer prozess das fängt schon an
damit dass am anfang nicht die
hauptzeugin gehört wurde also die frau
die kachelmann belastet sondern dass man
angefangen hat mit einer ganzen reihe
von ehemaligen freundinnen von ihm die
alle eigentlich zu der tat ja nichts
sagen können
so entstand eine situation
dass man
durchaus den eindruck gewinnen konnte
das gewicht lässt sich jetzt erst mal
erzählen was der für ein unsolides
liebesleben geführt hat um dann einen
recht schlechten eindruck von ihm zu
haben also das war ungewöhnlich und auch
sehr unschön
zeichnungen der ex geliebten die mit
fotos in der zeitschrift die bunte
auftraten dafür erhielten sie von dieser
illustrierten honorare zwischen 4000 und
50.000 euro
das machen alle großen magazin in
deutschland alle großen zeitungen das
ist absolut üblich es macht auch der
spiegel das macht auch der stern das
macht die bild -zeitung die bild am
sonntag also das ist ganz klar und wenn
wir geld gezahlt haben dann haben wir
das nicht gemacht um die frauen zu
manipulieren was sie uns erzählen sollen
sondern das ging dann wirklich darum
dass man gesagt hat okay die frau lässt
sich fotografieren das hat ja auch ein
paar stunden gedauert bis diese fotos
entstanden sind wir haben die frauen
abgedruckt in bunte wir sind europas
führendem people-magazin das heißt
europaweit kann jeder sehen auch die war
mit kachelmann zusammen das war eine der
haupt frauen von kachelmann und daran
ist auch überhaupt nichts verwerfliches
alle kommen aus dem loch alle kommen aus
dem grab nicht erheben sich die grab
deckel und da kommt auf einmal eine
geliebte nach der anderen die auch noch
was weiß und die auch noch im groll hat
aus alten tagen ich frage mich was das
soll und
und wenn kachelmann hier so war wieso
hat er dann die tat begangen also das
ist das sind alles zusammenhänge die
daher gestellt werden die sich für mich
nicht ohne weiteres sind die sich mir
nicht ohne weiteres als sinnvoll zeigen
trotz den zeitungs auftritten verlangen
die ex geliebten die öffentlichkeit
müsse bei der gerichts einvernahme
ausgeschlossen sei
also das ist also wirklich ein witz man
hat den eindruck der ausschluss der
öffentlichkeit oder diese möglichkeit
das 1 1 ein zeuge
alleine vor gericht aussagt der dient
heute weniger dem schutz seiner
intimsphäre oder seiner
persönlichkeitsrechte sondern eher dem
schutz der exklusivrechte von
fernsehsendern oder illustrierten naja
das kann widerspruch weil die frauen
haben natürlich in bunte nur einen
bruchteil dessen erzählt was sie vor
gericht erzählt haben also wir haben ja
wirklich das hat der teilweise acht neun
stunden gedauert die vernehmung der
frauen vor gericht das können wir ja gar
nicht abdrucken und diese ganzen
sexuellen details die die frauen erzählt
haben die haben wir gar nicht gedruckt
also deswegen ist das schon natürlich
auch verständlich dass die frauen darum
gebeten haben nicht öffentlich
auszusagen das gericht arbeitet nach dem
sogenannten unmittelbarkeit prinzip das
heißt ist ermittelt nochmals alles von a
bis z alle beteiligten müssten
erscheinen und werden nochmals ein
phänomen doch ihre aussagen werden nicht
protokolliert und weil die verhandlungen
in diesem fall sich über monate hinzieht
verblasst auf die erinnerung an die
ersten zeugenaussagen
was ein zeuge ein angeklagter oder sonst
wer in der hauptverhandlung sagt wird in
deutschland nicht protokolliert also
wird nicht von amts wegen
protokollierten natürlich schreibt jeder
mit manchmal jeder was anderes und
und es wird nicht aufgezeichnet das ein
großes problem
vor allem wenn man sich dann hinterher
anguckt was in den urteilen drin steht
die deutschen verteidiger fordern seit
jahren eine protokollierung von
hauptverhandlungen ich weiß nicht warum
das in deutschland so ein problem ist
das öffnet aber große lücken für
fehlurteile
nach dem auftritt der ex geliebten wird
das landgericht mannheim jetzt die
anzeigeerstatterin de an was sie genau
sagt erfährt die öffentlichkeit nicht
sie ist ausgeschlossen
das gericht befragt die
radio-moderatorin de insgesamt während
vier tagen und offenbar äußerst
gründlich
für verteidiger birkenstock wird ein
freispruch immer wahrscheinlicher die
würden befragung wird die wahrheit zu
tage mit jeder stunde über vernehmung
will ich zuversichtlich meines erachtens
hat
die von ihm und anzeigeerstatterin uns
unserem ziel der rehabilitierung des
herrn kachelmann sehr viel näher
gebracht
doch wenig später entlässt kachelmann
seinen verteidiger
also nach meinen informationen hat der
erste verteidiger noch an an dem samstag
oder
anträge geschrieben für den nächsten
verhandlungstag und dann hat eine sms
bekommen wir können seine arbeit
einstellen ich gehe davon aus dass es
dafür sehr ernsthafte gründe gibt ich
gehe davon aus dass herr kachelmann mit
einer verurteilung rechnet es kann
keinen anderen grund geben im letzten
drittel eines prozesses so dramatisch
den anwalt zu wechseln
ist es so gewesen dass herr birkenstock
insofern recht hatte als die faktenlage
ja finde verurteilung nicht gut war
insofern ja aber der optimismus schon
nachvollziehbar aber was er nicht
gesehen hat war dass diese faktenlage
keinerlei eindruck macht auf das gericht
das problem war dass offensichtlich ist
eine wahrnehmungs differenz gab zwischen
der verteidigung und dem gericht aber
wie die verteidigung die sache sieht
darauf kommt es nicht an denn die
verteidigung ist nicht am schluss für
das urteil verantwortlichen
vermutung vielleicht schätzt der
angeklagte seine situation
nach dem stand der bisherigen
beweisaufnahme realistischer ein als das
seine verteidiger seine bisherigen
verteidiger zumindest in der
öffentlichkeit publiziert haben ich weiß
es nicht wir aber eine naheliegende
erklärung zu dem zeitpunkt des
verteidiger wechsels wurde ja klar dass
noch weitere
ex geliebte geladen werden dass es dass
sich die verhandlung noch bis weit ins
nächste jahr hinein ziehen würde das hat
offensichtlich ein herr ackermann
beunruhigt es war ja an den an den
maßnahmen des gerichts erkennbar dass
hier jetzt kein ende in sicht der
sondern das jetzt weiter verhandelt
werden wird
und dass das auf eine verurteilung zu
läuft
das ist der neue mann der in jetzt
verteidigen soll johann schwenn aus
hamburg
haben sie war zeigt sich in der kurzen
zeit einzuarbeiten
bitte gehen sie in den sitzungssaal und
gucken sie genannt
wir kriegen ein bisschen satz gesagt
dass jetzt der eindruck entsteht wir
legen keinen wert auf das sie aus wie
den fotografieren
der neue anwalt schwenn das übernommen
hat hat er den gerichtssaal in einen
wirklichen rummelplatz verwandelt und
scheint es für das richtige zu halten
allen gegenüber gericht gutachter medien
eine demonstration der stärke zu machen
also hier tritt ein mann auf der alles
besser weiß der äußerst arrogant ist und
er alle einschüchtern zu meinem
entsetzen scheinbar auch das gericht er
versuchte dieses gericht
aufzuwecken oder oder zu sensibilisieren
eben führt für diese ganzen
falschaussagen indem er eben auf die in
die in die konfrontation gegangen ist er
hat sich mit allen angelegt ob das
ziemlich ist weiß ich nicht aber ich
glaube bei diesem gericht ist so mein
eindruck es ist egal was man macht die
machen ohnehin ihren stiefel ob man noch
irgendwie im gespräch bleibt oder ob man
ob man krieg aus ruft die sind an die
sind irgendwie völlig schmerzfrei die
richter lassen sich nicht in die karten
blicken freispruch oder verurteilung
beides ist möglich
inzwischen hält der neuen stil von
verteidiger schwenn einzug er hat alle
schwarzer vorlagen lassen weil er ihr
vorwirft sie hatte kontakt zu einem
zeugen gehabt das ist verpönt der
verteidiger beschäftigt sich sehr wenig
mit der sache dieser debatte steht
vielmehr zu bericht steht nämlich eine
ernste die frage ob jemand vergewaltigt
worden ist und methode bedroht worden
ist und er macht sehr viel klamauk ich
glaube dass muslimen haben und es wäre
schön wenn keine abschließende frage
noch abwehren das publikum war ganz ganz
ganz aufgeregt ja wo ist die schwarze
die schwarze die schwarze
die die journalisten draußen vor der tür
die fernsehleute erinnert die schwarze
was tatsächlich an dem tag passiert ist
nämlich diese aussagen der
rechtsmediziner die entscheidend waren
für diesen prozess das ist das ist
überhaupt nicht zur kenntnis genommen
worden das war alles nebensache es ist
der auftritt von professor markus
rothschild rechtsmediziner aus köln
gutachter der verteidigung
er vergleicht die aussage der
anzeigeerstatterin mit ihren
verletzungen die messerklinge kann diese
halsverletzung mit sicherheit nicht
verursacht haben sagt rothschild die
verletzung könnte mit einer feile oder
mit einem seil verübt worden sein also
ganz anders als geschildert rothschild
weiter sie sagt sie habe den angeklagten
mit den händen abgewehrt doch am
oberkörper sind keine abwehrverletzungen
zu finden dafür hämatome an den
oberschenkeln
wenn aber die tat so abgelaufen ist wie
sie sagt können diese nicht von
kachelmanns knien stammen er ist
anatomisch zu groß
und hat ein glasklares gutachten gemacht
also das war für mich
das herz aufgegangen dass es noch mal
dass es noch so rechtsmediziner gibt die
so klar und nachvollziehbar befunde
analysieren es war absolut überzeugend
und unterm strich eben es kann nicht so
gewesen sein wie die frau das gesagt hat
anschließend tritt der nächste gutachter
der verteidigung auf er hat sich auf die
analyse von verletzungen spezialisiert
die sich personen selbst beibringen
professor klaus püschel aus hamburg im
jahr 2009 habe sein institut
132 fälle sexueller gewalt untersucht
sagt fischer das ergebnis sei dass rund
ein drittel der angezeigten verletzungen
selbst beigebracht seien auch die
hämatome von d würde er aufgrund seiner
erfahrung in die kategorie selbst
beigebracht einordnen tische weiter noch
viel deutlicher ist das bei den
schnittverletzungen am bauch von d für
mich ist klar den kratzer hat sie sich
selbst beigebracht
sie hat einen also am bauch so ein
kratzer oder oberflächlichen haus kürzer
der
aus zwei ziemlich parallelen spuren
besteht und er sagt das kennt man von
von leuten die sich retten die einmal
runterfahren und einmal hochfahren ja
mit einem messer leicht die ritter auf
der haut hätten bei einem dynamischen
tatgeschehen anders aussehen müssen als
wie er sagte wie ruhig mit mit ruhiger
hand gemalt so wirkten die auf ihn und
die gewaltigen hämatome an den
innenseiten der oberschenkel hätten
wahrgenommen werden müssen von der
nebenklägerin während der vergewaltigung
solche gewaltigen hämatome wir tun sehr
weh bei der herstellung und da weiß man
sehr genau wurde hier kommen also man
fragt sich natürlich wenn sie sich die
die verletzung wirklich selbst zugefügt
haben soll mit welcher intensität
ist es passiert und kann man da wirklich
so abgebrüht sein dass man dann wirklich
diesen man eben anklagt einer
vergewaltigung tischler hat also sehr
schön nachweisen können dass das seine
auf was wohl seine überzeugung nach
selbstbeibringung ist ja und damit dann
habe ich mich dann habe ich mir gedacht
ja also wasser was haben wir denn nichts
nichts wir haben die schlechte aussage
der frau wir haben rechts rechts
medizinische befunde die auf eine
selbstverletzung hindeuten wir haben ein
tatwerkzeug an dem keine spuren dran
sind oder zumindest nicht die spuren die
man erwarten müsste ja was was wollen
wir was braucht man denn eigentlich noch
der tag ist eine niederlage für die
staatsanwaltschaft
staatsanwalt oltrogge will nicht vor der
kamera sprechen im gerichtssaal sagt der
journalisten dass er das alles zuerst
verdauen müsse
also immer noch 50 50 man weiß jetzt
nicht in die eine richtung in die andere
richtung deswegen ist dieser fall
natürlich auch so spannend weil man
das ist natürlich sehr spannend wie wird
das urteil ausfallen also glaubt die
kammer dem mutmaßlichen opfer oder sagt
man freispruch mangel mangels beweisen
man weiß es nicht ich
weiß nicht was noch alles passieren soll
oder was noch alles zusammenbrechen soll
bis die staatsanwaltschaft endlich mal
sagt
ja wir haben es versucht aber es ging
halt nicht und hier haben wir den fall
wirklich also ich ich ich fasse es nicht
ich weiß nicht wie man wie man hier mit
diesen beweisen oder diesen befunden wir
sind ja keine beweise gefunden mit
diesen befunden wie man da einen
menschen verurteilen will also
schleierhaft
von diesem prozess geht unabhängig von
der schuldfrage mann oder nicht schuld
ein fatales signal der einschüchterung
für opfer aus und das wird eben von
einer hemmungslosen selbstgerechten
aggressiven verteidigung wie die von
schwenn der ohne jeden respekt für alle
anderen beteiligten ist der nur howard
und mit macht seine sache durchkriegen
will wird das verschärft dieses signal
die geschichte ist ja die dass es eine
aussage gibt die nicht viel wert ist es
gibt eine vergewaltigungs aussage die
nicht viel wert ist es gibt keine spuren
die darauf hindeuten dass diese aussage
zutrifft es gibt kein geständnis
eigentlich gibt es gar nichts es gibt
rechtsmedizinische gutachten die sagen
es ist sehr wahrscheinlich dass die
nebenklägerin sich die verletzungen
selbst zugefügt hat ja und dann wird
trotzdem immer weiter prozessiert ich
frage mich warum man
das gericht das urteil fällt ist offen
im moment geht es von einem termin ende
mai aus
[Musik]